a careless and not deliberate error the
response of Nadeem zahawi only last
summer was appointed Chancellor of the
exchequer to claims that he agreed to
pay a penalty to settle a huge tax bill
it's reported that Mr zahari now Tory
chairman paid a 30 penalty on top of 3.7
million pounds in capital gains tax from
the sale of shares in his polling
company yougov making a total of 4.8
million pounds in a statement Mr zahari
said his father helped him set up the
company and in exchange received shares
in the business
following discussions with hmrc they
agreed that my father was entitled to
founder shares in ugov though they
disagreed about the exact allocation
said Mr zahawi They concluded that this
was a careless and not deliberate error
so that I could focus on my life as a
public servant I chose to settle the
matter and pay what they said was due
which was the right thing to do
but Mr zahar we did not say whether or
not he paid the hmrc a penalty
and earlier labor claimed his position
was untenable he was the chancellor of
the exchecker
collection the taxes that we now find
but he wasn't so Keen to pay himself so
if the Prime Minister wants to stick by
his commitment for integrity honesty and
professionalism he should do the right
thing and Sack Nadeem zahawi
have you been honest about your tax
Affairs Mr zahawi but as Mr zahari
continued to face questions about his
tax Affairs he was backed by a senior
cabinet colleague I can't speak for the
personal tax Affairs of a colleague but
what I would say is that Nadeem has been
very clear that he's paid all the tax
that he's owed that he's paid it on time
that there's nothing outstanding due
um and I think that's of course right
and proper but tax experts say Mr zahawi
should have been more careful for me
that's quite poor anyway I expect my
clients to take care when they give me
information
and when they declare their income and
their capital gains to me and I think
that's what we should expect of everyone
not least a government Minister Rishi
sunak is now facing new questions from
labor about what he knew and when about
Mr zahawi settling his tax bill but at
the same time the prime minister is
facing more ridicule over his failure to
our seat belt out while recording a
social media video in his car hi one of
my New Year's promises to you senior
Tories say Mr sunac has accepted he made
a mistake and has apologized while labor
says it revealed a lack of judgment
but it's Mr zahawi who's in bigger
trouble with questions about when he
settled his tax bill and whether it was
while he was Chancellor